Do you have any thoughts on the pushback of the supplement AHCC for immune function?
And if I have the MTHFR mutation step, then I shouldn't be taking methylated B supplements?
Well, you don't take methylated B supplements based upon your genetics.
You take methylated B supplements based upon a blood test measuring homocysteine.
That's just my opinion.
You go to 99 out of 100 other naturopaths, carpractors that do genetic testing.
If they do MTHFR defect testing, and they see a defect, they're going to put people on methylated
supplements.
That's where I differed opinion.
I'm sorry, I just think they're wrong.
So even if a person doesn't have cancer, I still think that's wrong.
For multiple reasons.
Now, I do list some of those in some of the videos, and I do have a blog post on should cancer
patients take methylated supplements that explains that, and I've kind of gone over it a little
bit already today.
But methylated supplements for somebody has cancer can be harmful because they can turn
it off the gene expression of tumor suppressor genes.
If you do that, your cancer can grow, you don't want to do that.
So no, I don't think you should be methylated B vitamins based upon genetic steps at all.
You take that based upon an only if you have elevated homocysteine levels.
I've taken my, measure my homocysteine, it's normal, well then don't take that, don't take
that.